Ah
entendi a fotografia como um veículo
para transportar ideias procura por isso
o produto limpakto para despertar a
atenção do leitor entre mais de 100
distinções André boto foi fotógrafo
europeu do ano 2010 vamos saber como
Olha o mundo
E aí
Oi bom dia a todos bom dia Leiria É
verdade o meu nome é André vou fotógrafo
essa coisas estranha que tem nome de
Hobby mas que até pode ser uma atividade
do tempo inteiro 120% Como é o meu caso
Ora bem
eu tento fazer algo de diferente ou de
menos comum por vezes fora do normal e
já tive até um professor que me apelidou
de anormal chamava misturando
apresentação pública é que eu estava
perto
Ok é um elogio e consigo entender isso
perfeitamente como um elogio e
provavelmente o melhor que me podem
chamar a precisamente quando para mim
esta é a minha forma de ver nos em quase
qualquer área mas principalmente nas
artes
devemos ter a necessidade de fazer algo
diferente ou de menos comuns queremos
entrar no mercado externo uma próprio
espaço o nosso próprio estilo e sermos
reconhecidos por fazer algo de menos oi
oi bem a diferenciação é algo que para
mim é muito importante e foi dessa forma
que eu consegui entrar entre aspas no
mercado e se calhar é isso me traz aqui
e acho que muitas vezes é necessário ver
o mundo que nos rodeia a ter uma
percepção daquilo que tá a volta de nós
um pouco diferente do normal é preciso
isso é uma palavra gigantesca Mas
recontextualizar ou seja 20 botar o
mundo e aquilo que nós temos a nossa
volta por muitas vezes
nós olhamos aquilo que nos rodeia e nós
estamos o olhar mas não estamos a ver e
muitas vezes simples objetos que nós
encontra volta se sofrerem uma alteração
em uma recontextualização
podem ser podem dar origem a imagens de
impacto e simplesmente com um objecto de
uma garrafa uma qualquer coisa que está
próximo às portanto este conjunto de
imagens São imagens que pode e pode-se
dizer que tem imagens comerciais há
sempre uma ideia por trás tem imagens
com pó solto muito simples e desde muito
simples é sempre uma ideia por trás de
cada imagem e também leitura
relativamente rápida portanto a Isto
pode ser uma forma diferente de nós
interpretar um sido de olharmos para
tudo que nos rodeia tem tanto te ver
tentando viver normalmente um pouco mais
vou tentar ver ao que
as pessoas não costumam aberto Ou seja
tentar estar atenta aos pormenores Este
sou eu e a minha cobra
e este Não não sou eu
o socialismo Eu tenho um projeto
Provavelmente o projeto mais importante
da minha vida até agora aí ainda tem uma
vida relativamente curtas para fazer
mais alguma coisa de importante
o socialismo que vocês vão ver um
conjunto de imagens relativamente
estranhas ou menos comuns a partir daqui
mas eu acho que nós come bichos humanos
que somos aí gosto de dizer que nós
somos bispos que às vezes somos mesmos
estranhos somos uma espécie de conjunto
de experiências vividas e isso reflete
não só é nós como pessoas mas também
naquilo que nós fazemos naquilo espalhar
enquanto artistas e sem refletir mais
portanto a se calhar entrasse avisar um
pouco antes de chegar à fotografia já
estava já tem uma ligação forte as artes
desenhava bastante importante aquilo que
me influenciou
basicamente foram três autistas três
autores se pode dizer que são realistas
que são eles o Salvador Dalí René
Magritte e principalmente mauritz O que
é ser teu nome estranho mas é
vulgarmente conhecido como é ser
portanto todos eles criavam os seus
próprios mundos muitas vezes com base
ilusão de ótica
levávamos para o mundo dos sonhos
portanto envolventes numa atmosfera
realista eu acho que é relativamente
simples nós como bicho humanos está no
realismo e deixando-se envolver pelo
socialismo porque provavelmente nós
deste sempre quisemos atingir o
impossível quisermos atingir a perfeição
a que vimos algo que não zera fácil
conquistar a processo Desde há muito
tempo para cá o homem Olhava O Céu vi os
passarinhos e pensava que está a mesma
altura que os passarinhos há muitos anos
mais tarde surgiram os primeiros
protótipos de alguma coisa que uns anos
mais tarde novamente
Ver se tornar
o primeiro avião e hoje o que é que
acontece temos o homem a conseguir voar
à a mesma altura dos Pássaros e muito
mais alto portanto isto esta história
aconteceu também comigo aí este desejo
de superação este desejo de atingir o
produzir o impossível foi com o motivou
a fazer este projeto Este trabalho
parece ser um pouco estranho mas que se
calhar começa a ganhar algum sentido
depois de aplicar um pouco aquilo que me
trouxe que fez chegar até aqui
e portanto
parte tudo nas tudo a partir de uma
ideia passe que tem por base o
socialismo e o nome do projeto é mesmo
esse realismo Oi e para mostrar um
bocadinho forma que mistura acontece é o
processo é relativamente simples e Tudo
começa com
e o nada eo nada costuma ser uma uma
imagem em branco e depois Este é o
início da construção Santista tudo feita
top
o recorte de imagem fundo céu coloração
umas Neves para dar ambiente uma rocha
ou equivalente ao primeiro plano outra
inverter é sempre importante fundir
outra inversão
importante nós às vezes andamos por isso
estamos praticamente os dias inverter
nem que seja a forma de pensar a tentar
fazer algo diferente
Ok um castelo recortar o castelo de tudo
certo colocar no local certo ajustar
tons e imagem final Porque isto é
basicamente o processo não é tão rápido
como aqui parece normalmente demora uns
diazinhos a conseguir fazer imagem ainda
demoram mais tempo a pensar antes de
fazer para que seja possível realizar
algo após não vemos na realidade
portanto Este é o mundo Este é o mundo
que me interessa representar e é aquilo
que gosta de fazer para tentar colocar
os outros a sonhar a sonhar comigo o OK
seguindo a mesma linha de trabalho tem
um projeto mais recente sobre Lisboa e
basicamente a forma de representação é a
mesma
Oi gente eu tive apenas monumentos
Lisboa e normalmente estes monumentos
Estão no local onde habitualmente os
podemos ver a na realidade
algumas vezes tu nesta imagem nós
podemos ter na mesma imagem a visão de
dentro e de fora do mesmo momento o que
normalmente não vemos a Isto pode ter
uma aplicação provavelmente para
fotografia
publicitária Mas é o mesmo estilo é
mesmo a linha de pensamento
adaptada a Lisboa especificamente
E aí
é bem
desde algum tempo a esta parte o meu
trabalho foi a viste como senti algo
muito complexo porque havia bastante
foto montagem bastante trabalho feito em
Photoshop
as próprias composições eram muito
cheias de elementos nós tínhamos muitos
por nós prever muitos por nós para ler e
então surgiu a necessidade de criar
alguma coisa que fosse mais simples como
- foto montagem com uma leitura para
então criar um projeto também um projeto
mais recente que é com base numa nuvem
com base nesta nuvem e sempre nesta
nuvem portanto mais uma vez trata-se de
rir contextualizar e tentar olhar o
mundo que nos rodeia de uma forma
diferente tentar atingir por vezes o
efeito-surpresa tentar fazer com que
quando os outros olham para mim nossa
fica impeça Epa este gajo é maluco como
é que ele conseguiu lembrar de uma coisa
é tanto que quando os outros pensem
comigo eu estou aqui alto apelidar de
maluco mas quando os outros pensões do
meu trabalho provavelmente é porque
estou no caminho certo e é porque estou
a conseguir fazer alguma coisa que
realmente se destaca
em relação ao que já existe isso é uma
coisa que me agrada e que me faz feliz
quando alguém pensa isso de mim e sobre
o meu trabalho
Esse é o meu tributo a maguito
em que utilizava muito este tipo de
representação que o senhor e o chapéu é
típico
portanto trata-se de apenas
reinterpretar aquilo que encontramos a
nossa volta qualquer objeto pode
facilmente
mostrar algo que não teríamos
habitualmente se nós atribuímos aquele
objeto uma função diferente para a qual
objeto foi criado a partida mas este
projeto ainda era muito complexo e quis
atingir algo ainda mais simples ainda
bom e sem falta uma taxa é absolutamente
nenhuma e então Criei um projeto
Ao qual eu chamo projeto de papel e
então é um projeto totalmente feito com
papel uma câmera tira de papel e é um
projeto este Talvez seja quase os
treinos da simplicidade pelo menos em
relação a tudo que eu já fiz até hoje em
que a trata-se de agarrar um objeto e
mostrar aquilo que de melhor é só objeto
tem para nos mostrar tanto uma simples
folha de papel uma simples tchau tchau
Que nós conhecemos como um objeto que
serve para escrever Ler fazer uma bola e
colocar no lixo pode ser algo que rim
deputados e visto de uma forma diferente
Assim espero ela possa gerar
imagens agradáveis e esse efeito
agradável aqui consegue pela presença de
muitas linhas e muitas linhas curvas o
que vai nós come e
agradável de ver
é importante gosto muito do desafio de
agarrar um simples objeto e tentar
mostrar o melhor de si objeto Santista
uma coisa relativamente simples de fazer
foi a grande objeto a local em cima da
mesa câmera fotográfica tripé e tempo
tanto quando está a chover na rua o
histórias não é obrigado a ficar em casa
e dormir
vamos mostrar para terminar um grande
vídeo e o vídeo que eles vão mostrar uma
coisa que normalmente quem faz meu tipo
trabalho não mostra apenas mostram
normalmente o resultado final o
resultado final eo resultado final é por
acaso gosto de mostrar o processo de
construção e como acontece tudo isto
principalmente para mim hoje é o que me
dá mais gozo verde é aquilo que vou
mostrar agora que é simplesmente um
vídeo de estudo que é que está a
acontecer em ritmo acelerado no
Photoshop vamos ver então
a
entrar
ligado
grande estou
ligado pô
E aí
a
entrar comprado tanto obrigado
Olá Tudo é possível se invertermos este
é o meu trabalho e Facebook YouTube meio
Obrigado a todos e espero que esteja
inspirado Obrigado até breve
obrigado a